let's talk about the la mayor's race
here before the end of the show because
you brought up a great point we have a
great new mayor
who uh or candidate
yeah caruso uh caruso and i i like this
guy because caruso built the americana
in glendale which is a disgusting
outdoor mall where animals go and they
eat it to cheesecake factory but he's
gonna build one another version of it
exclusively for homeless people and let
them play in the fountains and have fun
and [ __ ] wherever they want and i think
that's the move can you get up his ad
his advertisement oh yes yes they can't
get mad at us playing that no no no
rick caruso he's going to be the new
mayor
of los angeles because he is uh
he's very good at building malls
so he's going to fix the problem
because the homeless crisis is really
because
they don't have a mall
i don't think he put on youtube but i
bet i could find out he's live
thank you ben you don't have to
telegraph what you're doing you can just
deliver
um but i like if he goes he's like the
problem is that they don't homeless
people don't have a mall of their own
give them a mall
give them an outdoor mall where they can
conduct their business yeah give them a
chance nobody goes around in
anthropology something's fun something
fun
clear everyone out of h m let them go in
there
here's an ad he's running called faith
family and community
think nobody can clean up l.a yes meet
rick caruso
lifelong angelino
husband father grandson of immigrants
raised to put faith family and community
first a lifelong builder and job creator
that's right rick created the
southland's most beloved community
centers and he always shares that
success
what are you talking about
the americana is a beloved community
center
it's a corporate hellscape
it's a beloved community center people
in glendale don't know where to go yeah
i mean it's a big outdoor mall just a
community center
he hands out turkeys on thanksgiving
like frank lucas rick caruso's a
lifelong angelino
he's made billions of dollars building
outdoor malls
and now he's ready to build one for the
homeless
keep going ben
giving millions to provide health care
and a good education to kids in la's
poorest neighborhoods and giving
tirelessly of himself
first appointed by tom bradley he served
la under three different mayors fought
corruption and waste and cut crime 30
percent
i'm running for mayor because the city
we love is in a state of emergency
rampant homelessness people living in
fear for their safety and politicians at
city hall just in it for themselves my
only special interest is los angeles the
city we love
it's why i'll work for a dollar a year
and i won't take a dime from special
interest i'm already together
i'll work for a dollar a year i'm
already loaded
and i'm a little sick of this city
getting less comfortable for me and my
friends
so i'm going to work for a dollar a year
and we're going to use direct energy
weapons on the homeless
you pay me a dollar a year
and i will have the lap lapd out there
with batons
every day it'll cost the taxpayers only
a dollar a year
for me to vaporize homeless people in
the middle of the night
so you can feel safe going to the
americana in glendale and getting a
[ __ ]
herb crusted salmon at the cheesecake
factory for 48
i feel like the people in this don't
even know they're in a rick caruso ad he
just took photos of people
the city we love
finish this
we can clean up l.a read my action plan
at carusocan.com
rick caruso can clean up la
now get an interview of him up before we
get out of here because maybe i'm making
fun of this guy but
yeah i got one right here
maybe maybe this guy's got a plan
because you've lived here forever tell
people about it later real quick
uh it's a great place a lot of homeless
people well what's what are the
problems the homeless
and he's gonna handle it
look at this man
he's gonna fix it
rick caruso will work for a dollar
this [ __ ]
these dumb
slogans
i'll work for a dollar a year why the
dollar
just say you have to make something
i gotta
i gotta be able to go home and look at
my wife
so i need at least a dollar a year
let's see what maybe i'm wrong let's see
rick
about sort of what separates you because
ultimately this is a job interview right
and people got to pick who is the best
person for this
you have a different biography than most
of the other people that are running
where are you
the most qualified person to lead la
when a lot of the people you're running
against have a lot more experience in
government factory let me first talk
about them generally
which is an important question that
you've asked
they've had a lot of opportunity they've
had decades of public service to get
something done and they haven't they
failed and i just find it interesting
that you've got a group of people that
are tasked
with making the city safe and livable
and they've had a decade to get it done
they failed but they wanted
raise and a job promotion that wouldn't
happen anywhere else right and so if you
think they've done a good job i'm not
your candidate if you want more of the
same i'm not your candidate
let me tell you about rick caruso i've
worked hard i'm from humble beginnings
i love life i love giving back and i've
got a track record
of moving into a situation where there's
a serious problem or a crisis and fixing
it i came into lapd it was last summer
at the cheesecake factory at the
americana there was a crisis
because
one of the chefs
was drunk every day and he was burning
the chicken fish
and if you know anything about the
cheesecake fact we got great chicken
fingers in there so what i did was i
sent him to a rehabilitation program and
brought in another chef who was actually
my deadbeat cousin my deadbeat cousin
came in there and he actually did a
great job but that's the kind of
experience i have
under a federal consent decree run by a
federal judge crime was spiking
i reformed lapd hired bill bratton we
dropped crime by 30 percent that was a
crisis situation
asked to step up at usc
we turned usc around with a lot of help
from leadership but that's a very
different enterprise today this works
the only people committing crime in this
city will be the cops
[Laughter]
if my plan is
if my plan is enacted the only dangerous
people in this city will be the police
i want to restore la back to the rampart
pd days
as we know the lapd is a great
institution and i'm proud
proud to i reform them that involved
telling them hey hey
do it quietly
i reform the lapd with my do it quietly
program
do it quietly
[Laughter]
where we
encourage cops to behave exactly as they
were but quietly you bust that guy's
head in quietly
i'll make a big deal about everything
see the rest of this i'm you know what
this guy's i i'm starting to believe in
him
yeah he's good four years ago when i
took over his chair
and i have this passion about los
angeles and we're in a crisis that's
what it is let's say what it is
and i've got a track record
of being able to manage through a crisis
lead
i'll hold myself accountable i'll make
tough decisions
and i'm not looking for another job
i want to be mayor i want to get a job
done and go home i'm not looking at
making decisions through a political
lens to get reelected like all of my
other candidates who are running are
doing uh and when you say usc you were
chairman of the board of trustees at usc
uh fight on so
let's talk about because we know the two
biggest issues right now you lead with
them in your campaign why don't we ever
see the faces
let's start with this milo yiannopoulos
[Laughter]
why don't we why don't we ever see the
face of the interviewer this is
incredibly disturbing have you ever seen
an interview like this
you don't even see the face of the
interviewer
i mean what is happening i guess fox 11
only brought one camera yeah
and why is he being interviewed in a
restaurant i don't know it's like what's
going on
all right keep going all right all right
i'm some of your critics point to the
fact that you supported george gascon
for district attorney do you regret that
and do you now support his uh recall
so i knew george when i was the
president of the police commission and
he was a deputy chief and he wanted to
be chief i didn't make him chief he
wasn't ready for it at the time and i
hired bill bratton
now he left and became the chief at mesa
arizona that went up to san francisco
i knew a very different george now what
happened to george on his journey from
mesa to san francisco that changed the
way he thought about fighting crime is
very different than where he was so
early in his campaign i did support him
he was a friend i knew him
from from our time to get lapd once his
campaign started rolling out and i was
hearing about what his plans were i
quickly pivoted and i gave to jackie
lacy and i gave her a significant amount
of money to support her so
i regret what george has done and i
think george either needs to stand up
and say the policies that i've put into
place are harming our communities and
i'm going to change them or he should
step down and if he doesn't step down he
should be recalled because he is harming
our communities and i stand with charlie
beck
and i stand with bill bratton that said
the same thing this was a different
george than we all knew when we worked
at lapd together i don't know what's
happened but clearly he's got to change
or he's got to go the other big issue is
homelessness yep
number one thing you're going to do
that's going to be different than the
people that have been in there so far
day one declare a state of emergency
move the authority into the mayor's
office i'll be accountable to fix it i'm
going to build the smartest team in the
country to go fix the problem we're
going to go build
30 000 temporary beds we've got excess
land throughout the city that's declared
surplus land
we're going to give people an option to
move into a clean safe place in a very
humane way give them the right services
that they need mental health physical
health
but you don't get a choice to stay on
the street anymore the minute we have a
bed for you
otherwise there's a consequence to being
on the street you you have to draw a
bright line
that we've got communities you have to
go down
whatever demographics what you have to
do
is you have to do the best finishes
you have to really do indoor outdoor
living because a lot of them are outdoor
anyway you have to do indoor outdoor
living you need large windows lots of
natural light
you need buildings with gyms you know we
need to move them into into luxury yeah
yeah so we're going to build all these
luxury units and if the homeless people
can't afford them we just sell them to
foreign
billionaires but the most important
thing
we're going to give the homeless people
the option to get a job that pays a lot
of money and move into these units for
18 000 a month and if they can't afford
that we're gonna just get put these
units on the market at market value and
we'll leave the homeless exactly where
they are
that are severely impacted by
encampments you can't tolerate it
anymore when you say there's a
consequence what does that mean you're
arrested you probably are arrested if if
we give you a bed and we give you the
services and we clean you and we feed
you and support you and i think there
should be retraining programs to get
people back on their feet that can get
back on their feet
why then should we allow people to live
on the street good point and where do
you draw that line
you can't and that's what's happened
with this problem everybody has been
so politically correct in their mind
whatever that means to deal with it
the problem has just gotten larger let's
talk about your place in this race um
you live a very comfortable lifestyle
after working really hard and being very
successful in business that is the
american dream right right but the
average american doesn't live your
lifestyle the average los angelino
doesn't live your lifestyle how do you
relate to somebody who's struggling to
pay the bills
well let me tell you again i grew up
with immigrant parents from italy that
lived in boyle heights and my
grandfather was a gardener and i
remember riding in his truck and i
remember a family
that lived from paycheck to paycheck
there was always a meal on the table
always my father was an italian fascist
he was a supporter of mussolini
how do you relate to the regular people
my father was a fascist who supported
mussolini they lived paycheck to
paycheck and he used to read books on
hitler
so i know exactly what people in this
country are going through right now
i can relate to all of them
thank you so much